hidden facts that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
another question where's the manifesto
we're getting out first answers tonight
according to the New York Post and we
just learned this moments ago that
Hale's writings could be released but
only after the FBI analyzes and we
assume scrub some of the content
as we told you last night in Instagram
messages to an old teammate minutes
before the massacre Hale said she left
behind quote more than enough evidence
and that one day this will make more
sense well predictably lgbtq groups are
desperately lobbying to keep it all
under wraps
media Outlets which are supposed to be
interested in actual effects are oddly
subdued about the prospect of learning
more about the Killer's motives
now we have no idea what was in Ms
Hale's mind why she targeted the
Covenant School but it is clear that if
this is a case of anti-christian hate we
all should know all about it including
how it was inspired
and no matter what her writings contain
they should be aired publicly and in
full
no we don't want some sanitized version
now let's State the obvious
if word leaked that somewhere in the
manifesto she praised Trump or that it
included references against illegal
immigrants or minorities or if the
shooter was let's say an MR NRA member
who attended the First Baptist Church
somewhere if any of those scenarios were
present reporters would be raising holy
hell for authorities to release all
information but not here
the fact is Democrats and their friends
in the Press are worried that the more
we find out about this disturbed young
woman the more we could see how the
killer was shaped by this entire
atmosphere we've created
unstable people are especially
susceptible to poisonous ideology we
already know that some of the less
radical Fringe groups are viciously
anti-christian
now look at how they attack churches and
pro-life centers over the last few years
and there's a trans day of Vengeance
planned for this Saturday
menacing videos are being posted online
to promote it
now not a peep about this from the doj
of course and this week Merrick Garland
refused to address even a possible hate
crimes angle in this Nashville shooting
do you plan on opening a hate crime
investigation
for the targeting of Christians
the FBI and ATF are both on the scene
working with the local police as of now
a motive hasn't been identified
this is about politics pure and simple
now Democrats have invested a lot in the
storyline that white American Christians
are the most dangerous people on the
face of the planet
remember that group they're the real
enemies you have these young people
who've organized online who call
themselves America First really I view
that as a slogan as a way to say we are
white nationalists Christian
nationalists believe the United States
was established as an explicitly white
Christian Nation and any threat to their
agenda must be stamped out even if that
means violence if you're talking about
people who uh believe in in ethno state
or of a religious
um theocracy
the same the same type of people who are
the good people are those who embrace
your gender fluidity in your evolving
identity
but this shooting May turn that Dynamic
on its head
that's the framing that the Democrats
will support is the one of course
advancing gun control
why in God's name do we allow these
weapons of war on our streets and at our
schools so I again call on Congress to
pass the assault woman's man pass it now
he knows this would have zero chance of
getting past but he doesn't care it's a
good deflection tactic for him
with a 32 percent approval rating on the
economy Biden does not want to talk
facts so he either hides them or he lies
about them
extreme Maggie Republicans are
threatening to undo all this progress
they're putting our economy in Jeopardy
by threatening to refuse to pay
America's bills
[Applause]
the Biden economy yeah
with responding to the fact is 2023
style liberalism it's failing miserably
all over on the federal state and local
levels
now take the inconvenient facts coming
out of our nation's capital DC has
always kind of been a perfect test case
for liberalism its residents have among
the highest per capita income in the
United States around 230 thousand
dollars if you can believe it a super
majority of Democrats throughout the
city government they run things
and what have they delivered well
homeless tents have popped up all over
this city drugged out zombies walking
through Union Station and into the Metro
Office Buildings half empty and
naturally the crime is a huge problem
over the past six years of plummeting
numbers of police homicides have
increased 75 percent armed carjackings
have increased 227 percent armed
robberies have increased 46 percent and
most tragic and alarming is that last
year alone the juvenile homicide rate
doubled
and the chief says they're down about
500 officers and a current police force
of about 3 400. but council members in
D.C all Democrats say this whole crime
thing is overblown
with regard to Crime while perception is
important the reality is less concerning
when it comes to Crime how people feel
is important but there is not a crime
crisis in Washington D.C
hiding the facts again but there's no
doubt about it criminals know that they
have the upper hand here
we need to keep violent people in jail
right now the average homicide suspect
the average homicide suspect has been
arrested 11 times prior to them
committing a homicide
so what's responsible for this guns well
DC has some of the toughest gun laws in
America
no
you can thank black lives matter and
anyone who helped whip up the anti-law
enforcement frenzy that led to the
hiring and retention problems Coast to
Coast
and let's not forget of course to thank
Corporate America for high crime because
they wrote fat checks to corrupt
activists who bought luxury homes
so hiding the truth about how soft on
crime policies destroys Public Safety
Democrats shift back to their old
standbys let's talk about what happened
on January 6th and we had well over a
thousand folks so far that have been
arrested and that was here I'm sure that
that's affecting the numbers for a crime
in D.C when we're looking at that
overall number
well that sums it up in a nutshell
Democrats believe that old ladies
walking through the halls of Congress
taking selfies are a bigger threat than
murderers and repeat violent offenders
Americans deserve the straight facts not
in an agendas
on all the challenges we Face crime the
economy our schools China our Mental
Health crisis if we're going to make any
progress on any of these issues we need
leaders who are not afraid to tell the
truth no matter who it offends and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else